[Musica]
allora vi spiego è estranea la mappa se
diciamo che le creature un po un
visionario secondo me e se tu guardi la
zona rossa tipo di mezzo alla giungla
tipo io penso che rientri muri nella
vita le aree anche solo guardare ragazzi
c'è un problema perché tu sei lì perché
sono qui
male li sta già giocando gli amici gioco
al centro dell'isola come song air games
ci sono le armi da prendere in mezzo all
isola però è pieno zeppo di code che ti
ammazzano ci sono delle mine per terra
delle trappole per terra e piani zombie
quindi prendete le armi ognuno per sé è
vincolata e mezzo come sulla sfera il
canta o ferma dopo metà corsa e mezzo
siamo già ma chi è che andavano affatto
il gioco l'ha fatto il gioco ma guarda
io dovevo salire sopra le ha fatto il
gioco ci sono armi ha sì ci sono e non
ci sono anche un al centro le armi a
tempo ma perché non riesco ad una
limetta aiuto aiuto che al toro falsari
morton e gli hunger games me lo sarei
meritato due paesi stiamo utilizzando
sperare io sono morto sono troppo sono
crudo bene a me io sono morto il
sopravanza sopravvivere se riesco girato
tantissimo a morte sull'ultimatum una
trappola e basta di certo è anche che in
silvio che morì per sempre perché figata
cosa fai se no gli esperti gli altri fdv
altresì rispetto agli altri scappano in
pieno rappo le ma che figata
ciao ma sai quanto massei quanto tempo
ho aspettato sta roba
sai quanto tantissimo è bellissima e non
la facevano mai ma attenti dove avete
piegati simile rare piena mi guarda
estetiche campera e mezzo cosa stai
facendo tutte le armi del gioco a rete
che qualcuno è morto per e ti ha preso
la zona
non ho visto niente non so niente mi ha
detto che il divisionario perché
ora che si muove che ammazza gli zombie
delle mine e per terra che esplodono
che schifo di essere umano a me sembra
barriera invisibile di passione a quanto
lui fatto loro tantissimo proprio ancora
fatto ma york ma che fa prese questa e
lucine quasi eletto chiti si fanno un
botto di danno quanto ti ho levato
tantissimo gravissima come un fatto non
ci divertiva e 360 modalità i 200 di
vita decente di shields 200 di figli ho
paura che qua succedono robe dietro di
me avete solo i due è quindi non sono
stato capito ma perché abbiamo sempre io
stesso alla fine ma io di oberstar
fondamento è figure mio io ho visto
talmente troppo hunger games che non
posso permettere
ma comunque tu l'hai visto pietro è che
la sai la mappa quale perché mauro fissi
infatti l'ho vista uguale che vale l'ha
fatta per la ieri games team non c è un
buchi per terra con trappole e 19 18
meno avvertono resa un po più capito
però una copertura che in tribuna e
fantastico a me è sceso tipo una
barriera invisibile quindi non so
neanche come avrei dovuto vederla però
va bene è stato geniale comunque fatto
tutto questo farà molto comodo
ok mancato non è capace giocare solo
perso e non posso parlare io non so
giocare più st villar e
l'uso giocare neville dandone senza che
maletti batte roiano vinto io
wow ma io voglio fare un'altra questo
sistema è geniale bellissimo 321 sì ma
maledizione maledizione da dire se
stessi un incubo tutto tranne il
cecchina mezzo di casi non s'è capito
niente
ma perché tutti contro di me ho capito
sei pietro basta perché dove di vita ma
michele giocatore ma questo trovi
buchetti da puoi sparare solo fatto
morire
non lo so bocchetti quegli squali non è
possibile
e niente stavo scappando nella ma è
stato difficilissimo e tanto ci mette
tutti vicini c'è proprio questa è una
cosa si scrive o dice anche madonna
ragazzi all'ag all'inizio cioè e
tantissima devastante orribile io ho
visto voleva verso favi come perché sai
che vantando la vera domanda è come fa
lui a sapere questa cosa possa dire no
chi è che mi chiedo cosa sei ma spiegami
si l'osservatore nelle cose ma facendo
ma basta telecronista sparati però la
tanto posti tanto vasti qui da qualcuno
vicino
l'hacker male è che io mi spara e spari
malissimo qui battaglia campale capito
non sono in ricarica sono più vita dove
che trappole pieri trappole qua apriremo
poco ancora di riprenderla 20
controversi sto vedendo tutto il tempo
una hit ma perché non me ne vado aspetta
adesso ho capito cosa devo fare la mia
vita è arrivato è arrivato uno contro le
va beh non c'è io nostra proposta
diventerà l'immagine
uno stupendo ma quanto basta maglietta
molto molto
no io a picco nei secoli fatto danno per
la prossima volta di un sindaco si fa
vedere se la persona odiosa non merita
niente e all ultima quella l'ultima
fatta recentemente non è lultima siamo
io subito nuova regola non si può
comprare al centro ok ok a sparare a me
ma sente già sparando al centro per che
cosa sta gente ma non riesco a salire
sulle rocce perché si sta faticando per
preparare bene via tutti hanno preso le
armi al centro c'è pieno basta con
franchezza su di me non ho capito bene
mi sta scalando la norma non fatevi
prendere un arma trasmetterla vede tutti
contro dinara pulsante santi ma c'e
niente che io dai fps marito ma si stima
di te non riesco curarvi senza però
perché è fatto aiutare il centro no no
tranquillo si sta al centro delle
foreste
raga non vedo niente non sono chiuso per
a di tutto lui è nemmeno passato o tre
api e devi morire ma mai riesco a
prenderti lo squalo non ci credo
maledizione per la fine di novembre
mio dio pie schifo mori ma basta
maledizione quelle ovvero fucile a pompa
ma dai incastrano lo scoglio aia chiama
le due miss è finito un incastrata anche
lui incantata benessere altro scudo ice
una vita piena di questa di fatto e alla
cieca proprio del fatto che avrebbe
chiuso gli occhi e province gigi giteau
nell'isola ho vinto io zitti gioco è
rapidissima ma ragazzi non si capisce
nulla ai ragazzi ringrazio pietro rialzo
stefani a soffrire per aver partecipato
agli hunger games in quattro per è stato
molto divertente
iscrivetevi al canale che lasci
descrizione era come sempre ci vediamo
[Musica]